russia's cruel and unprovoked invasion
has spurred the international community
into action
and today's meeting is just another sign
of the way that nations of goodwill are
rising to the moment
the security assistance that we are
rushing to ukraine as making a real
difference
in real time
and everyone in the contact group has
been inspired by the courage of the
ukrainian people
and the skill of the ukrainian military
and that's why ministers and chiefs of
defense from some 50 countries
joined us today at our meeting uh there
is a grinding war of attrition that is
occurring in the in the luhansk donbass
region lujan stanis the two oblasts of
donbass and to answer your question
about is the donbass lost no it's not
lost yet uh the ukrainians are making
the russians pay for every inch of
territory that they gain
and and advances are measured in
literally hundreds of meters on on some
days you might get a kilometer or two
out of the russians but not much more
than that so high cost battle of
attrition grinding uh not lost yet uh in
in in the donbass and the ukrainians
intend to continue the fight
today the ukrainians are effectively
employing
these high mars with strikes against
russian command and control nodes their
logistical networks their field
artillery and their defense sites and
many other targets
these strikes are steadily degrading the
russian ability to supply their troops
command and control their forces and
carry out their illegal war
of aggression
the fact that the ukrainians were able
to quickly deploy these systems
speaks highly of their ability their
ingenuity their artillery ability their
gunner capability their determination
and their will to fight
as of today we have transferred 12
highmars to ukraine
this is part of more than 20
that the united states and our allies
have committed
trained also or 200 ukrainians on the
high mars and that training continues
with many more um
i'm sure that uh ukrainian leadership
will be
pleased to hear lavra's confirmation of
the effectiveness
of not only that system but how they're
using that system
as you know russians are currently in
uh
kirsan
and zaphonesia so the russian forces
they're they're there now so you have to
wonder who he's talking to
you've heard us uh mention this before
in terms of what uh what putin's
objectives are
you know he
he has stated a number of times that you
know this is a limited operation focused
on uh on the donbass uh his actions have
proven uh
otherwise and and we have known uh are
suspected not suspected but known uh our
allies and partners have known that he
has greater ambitions and live rob just
confirmed that today so
again
no surprise to anybody that's been a
part of this or even watching this
remotely may be a surprise to the
russian people who putin has been lying
to the entire time
uh it was just yesterday that we warned
in no uncertain terms of russia's plans
to annex additional russian excuse me
ukrainian territory
in that the russian government is
reviewing detailed plans to purportedly
annex a number of regions inside ukraine
including kerasan and zaparizia and now
that that invasion is well underway now
that that invasion has
proven itself to the world to be nothing
more than a war of territorial conquest
a war of territorial aggression the
likes of which we haven't seen
since mid
last century
it is no surprise that foreign minister
lavrov and others continue to try to put
the blame on the west
you